A few years back, news headlines mentioned
names like BT COTTON, BT
BRINJAL and so on!
And even the markets were flooded with them!
Any idea what these are?
That’s right!
These are genetically modified crops,
abbreviated as GM plants.
We have heard about them several times!
These
plants are the modified versions of the original
variety.
Modifications in the
plants add many advantages like greater yield,
insect resistance, nutritional
value and so on!
But how do we modify the plants?
How is the transformation carried out?
For
that, each plant part acts as a mini laboratory!
Several experiments are carried
out on EACH PART.
At the end of many such experiments, finally
a product is
achieved that has the desired characters!
So in order to make useful products, we modify
the crops.
But in order to
modify them, we need to study each and every
part of plants in detail.
In this, and in the upcoming sessions, let
us learn and understand each part of
the plants in detail.
And where do we begin with?
The top or the bottom?
Let’s toss and choose
which part to begin with!
If it’s heads, we begin with the shoot,
and if it’s tails,
we begin with the roots!
So let’s get started!
Here we go!
We have got tails!
So now let us begin with studying a typical
plant beginning
with the roots and moving to the shoots!
Let us start our understanding of the
roots first!
There are three major areas of study that
we need to carry out!
First is the
TYPE of roots, second is the various REGIONS
or PARTS of the roots.
And lastly
we will study the various MODIFICATIONS of
the roots!
Four topics to be discussed:
- Types of roots
- Regions of a typical root
- Modifications of roots
Let us begin with the types of roots first!
Here we see a carrot and an onion in the soil.
If we uproot both the plants, where can you
locate the roots in both of these?
Well, this complete structure of a carrot
is like a root!
Yes!
In case of carrot,
this complete structure is the main root which
is edible!
On the other hand, in
case of this onion, we find these small, bunch
like structures.
These are its
roots!
So can we say that there are two major types
of roots?
Well, there are various types of roots found
throughout the plant kingdom!
But
we will restrict ourselves to three major
types!
The first one is the category of carrots!
These types of roots are called
Taproots!
The second type is the one in which there
are bunch like structures.
The ones found in this onion!
These are called the fibrous roots.
And the last
type, which we are yet to discuss, is called
as adventitious roots.
This type
involves the roots which arise from other
parts of the plant body, and not the
main roots, below the stem!
Don’t get confused!
Let us understand each type
better
Taproot system is the one in which there is
a single root which is the primary
root that anchors the plant.
The one seen in this case.
There are several secondary and tertiary roots;
that is these smaller root like
structures which arise from the primary root!
The primary root has the
tendency to grow deeper in the soil.
Usually, dicot plants exhibit the taproot
system.
The second type is that of the fibrous root
This type does not contain a
single primary root.
Rather, many smaller roots come together to
form a bunch
like structure.
These roots usually do not grow too deep,
unless the tree is very
huge!
And what kind of plants exhibit this type
of system?
That’s right!
Monocots usually have the fibrous root system!
Now comes the last type from our list.
That is the adventitious root system!
This type deals with the roots that unusually
originate from the other parts of
plants like the branches, stem, leaves or
even some old woody roots at times.
Have you ever seen a huge Banyan tree?
Any idea what these string like structures
are?
Well these are actually the
ROOTS!
Yes!
A banyan tree like this one has these string
like structures.
These
are the prop roots which arise from the branches!
These roots are called aerial
roots which are a type of adventitious roots.
As we can see here, the roots
arise from the aerial parts, the branches.
They grow from above the ground.
And they firmly adhere to the ground, giving
the huge tree a proper structural
support as well!
Note that a banyan tree does have a proper
root system under
the ground.
The adventitious roots are just additional
ones that help in making
a few systems work efficiently in the plant
body.
This is one example of
adventitious roots.
Now before moving ahead with the next section,
let us revise the types of
roots once.
The first type is that of the taproots.
This type has a single, long
primary root system and smaller, secondary
and tertiary roots arising from it,
just like in case of carrots.
The second type is the fibrous roots.
In this type,
several smaller roots come together to form
a single bunch like structure, just
like in case of onion roots.
Lastly, we have the adventitious root system.
Here, the roots arise from different parts
of the plant like the stem, branches,
leaves and so on.
The prop roots of the banyan tree can be considered
as a
good example of the adventitious roots!
This was about the types of roots.
We shall have a look at the next topic that
is regions or the parts of the roots in
the upcoming video!
Do subscribe to our channel to get updated
about the
launch of our next video!